hey what is up everybody it's animak
here for anime uproar and joyboy has
returned luffy seemingly died and then
came back to life and a new power
awakened inside of him a power that
could be a completely new form a devil
fruit awakening or something even more
insane the one piece story has reached
the point at which a massive reveal like
this had to happen in order to set up a
proper final showdown on laughdale but
by making this reveal oda may have just
spoiled luffy's true power and how this
incredible story will finally end so
let's get into it if you guys enjoy our
one piece content and you want to see
more leave a quick like and comment it
only takes a second but it helps with
that youtube algorithm and remember that
subscribing and hitting that
notification bell is a very real way of
directly supporting the channel and it's
completely free if you're looking for
more one piece content to watch we have
an entire playlist on one piece i will
link it down in the description finally
this video will contain spoilers for the
latest one-piece manga chapters so
please proceed with caution you have
been warned so in the most recent
chapters of the manga the cp-0 members
on wano learned that the gorosei have
issued a critically important edict
straw hat luffy must be eliminated at
once he must not be allowed to defeat
kaido he must be stopped right here and
now as soon as we hear this we all
immediately wondered why the gorosei are
so determined to kill luffy at this very
moment they are not even willing to wait
for kaido to take care of luffy despite
the fact that kaido is known as the
world's strongest creature a creature
who seemingly cannot die and yet the
gorosei seem to think that luffy has a
chance of defeating him because the
nameless cp zero agent with that white
bowler hat seemingly sacrifices his life
in order to interfere in the fight
between luffy and kaido as a result of
the agent's interference luffy takes a
massive blow from kaido head on he is
then sent crashing to the ground he
loses consciousness and he is defeated
the narrator even confirms that kaido is
the winner of the battle momo also says
that he can no longer hear luffy's voice
and kaido then declares that monkey d
luffy is dead
at this point it doesn't look great for
luffy and if he wasn't the main freaking
protagonist we might have been tricked
into thinking that he had actually died
but luffy is the main protagonist and as
the chapter comes to an end we see
luffy's supposedly lifeless body begin
to smile
steam is rising from his body and his
hair has turned into some sort of goop
as if it's melting it is also implied
that luffy's heart had in fact stopped
beating but then it started up again the
japanese word used to describe luffy's
smile as he comes back to life is nika
as in the sun god nika and as all of
this is happening zunesha arrives
zunesha who is now confirmed to have
been a companion of joyboy 800 years ago
says the following momonosuke i can hear
it how long it's been i hear the drums
of liberation for the first time in 800
years he is here joy boy has returned
what an incredible chapter what an
insane cliffhanger and as you might
expect this unbelievable turn of events
has made the one piece community lose
its mind and for once it's completely
justified the long-awaited joy boy has
returned he is clearly implied to be the
same person as the legendary sun god
nika and luffy who was supposed to be
dead has now come back to life with some
sort of new form or new power or devil
fruit awakening or all of the above okay
so let's talk about joy boy and nika
what we know about them so far and how
both of these legendary and mythical
figures seem to have awakened within one
man monkey d luffy on the ryugyu
ponoglyph a man from the surface known
as joyboy apologizes to the people of
fishman island for breaking his part of
an ancient promise
this apology was written during the void
century and the nature of the letter
shows that this joy boy had a strong
connection to the people of fishman
island despite the fact that he himself
was from the surface this is significant
in and of itself because although our
knowledge of the void century is
obviously limited due to everything else
we know about the history of the one
piece world it is safe to assume that
back then the fishmen were actively
discriminated against by people on the
surface and yet joy boy clearly wasn't
one of those who discriminated against
them and i think this is important joy
boy is believed to have lived some 900
years ago so at the beginning of the
void century but since the poneglyphs
are believed to have been invented by
the cosgry clan 800 years ago the ryugyu
poneglyph must have been created around
the end of the void century so there
seems to be a gap of about 100 years
between the time that joy boy is
believed to have made the promise and
the time that the ryugyu ponoglyph was
created in terms of the promise itself
the people of fishman island promised to
keep noah safe until a certain day
keeping noah safe was part of their
promise and joyboy's part of the promise
was most likely that he would use the
power of poseidon to bring noah up to
the surface it is also likely that
noah's true purpose is to serve as an
ark that would relocate all of the
people of fishman island up to the
surface which is something that many of
them have dreamed of for centuries but
were not able to achieve due to all the
discrimination again we have to
emphasize that joyboy is someone from
the surface who not only refuses to
discriminate against the fishmen but
actually wants to liberate them and
bring them up to the surface i think
this tells us a lot about joyboy and it
draws a clear parallel between him and
the legend of sun god nika joyboy is
also the man who left a priceless
treasure known as the one piece on a
mysterious island at the end of the new
world this island was discovered by
goldie roger 25 years ago and it is
likely where the entire story will
ultimately culminate
since the people of fishman island
continue to faithfully watch over noah
in order to keep their end of the
promise to joyboy it has always been
implied that joyboy will one day return
to fulfill his part of the promise and
now we know that he has indeed returned
even if we don't know all the precise
details just yet
now let's talk about nika a legendary
warrior who was worshipped as the sun
god by slaves in ancient times the
legend of nika says that he would one
day come to liberate all the slaves and
bring smiles to their faces and again
bringing freedom and joy to those who
are oppressed is something that clearly
both joyboy and nica have in common
combine this with zunisha talking about
the drums of liberation and there is a
strong implication that nika and joyboy
are the same person an ancient warrior
who wanted to liberate those who were
enslaved and oppressed including of
course the fishman luffy appears to be
the modern embodiment of this ancient
warrior and so he may be destined to
succeed where the original joy boy
failed the most recent chapters
foreshadowed this very thing because
during the battle between kaido and
luffy we saw that luffy was going all
out and trying to surpass his limits
because he is so concerned about the
people of wano he knows that if he loses
to kaido the people of wana will
continue to be enslaved and they will
not even have clean water to drink as
their homeland continues to be polluted
by kaido's factories this is the primary
driving force behind luffy's desire to
defeat kaido he wants to liberate the
people of wano from their enslavement
and this is a goal that is certainly
consistent with the idea that luffy is
the modern embodiment of joy boy and
nika it is possible that luffy's noble
motivations contributed to the fact that
he came back to life as joy boy
meanwhile kaido who was himself once a
potential candidate for being the modern
joy boy has the exact opposite goal he
wishes to continue enslaving the people
of wano for his own ends and the fact
that they dared rebel against him means
that he is now justified in treating
them even more severely than ever before
maybe kaido had embodied the spirit of
joyboy at some point in the past but
that is clearly no longer the case on
the other hand luffy fully embodies the
true spirit of joy boy and nika and that
is almost certainly why he is now
undergoing this incredible
transformation right before our eyes
but speaking of this new goopy
transformation what exactly is happening
here is luffy simply awakening a new
gear or new form is he awakening a new
ability is his devil fruit itself
awakening or is the actual spirit of joy
boy nika awakening inside of him is this
new resurrected luffy going to be the
same monkey d luffy that we love or is
he going to be different now because a
new consciousness has awoken inside of
him is luffy going to become the
historical person known as joy boy is he
going to stay the same but just unlock
new powers or is it going to be some
combination of the two
these are the big questions that we need
to talk about right now the best place
to start is luffy's devil fruit because
the manga has been hinting heavily that
the gomugomi is far more important than
we had ever imagined it seems clear that
luffy's fruit is not actually called
gomugomunomi it's true name was hidden
by the world government because this
devil fruit is a secret legendary fruit
that hasn't awakened for centuries this
devil fruit is so dangerous that the
world government tried to keep it
completely under wraps but shanks
managed to steal it from the world
government and then luffy accidentally
ate it when he was still a kid but
assuming that luffy's fruit is this
legendary fruit that hasn't awakened in
centuries why is it so dangerous was
this the original joy boy's fruit and
does it still have some part of him
inside of it perhaps his will or some
special power that he possessed is this
even a rubber fruit at all or could it
be something else entirely and the
rubber may just be one small aspect of
its true powers i mean this could just
be a standard devil fruit awakening
maybe similar to katakuri's mochi
mochinomi which has many similar
properties to the gomugomonomi so luffy
could develop something like the ability
to transform his body more like a logia
user he may even end up being able to
turn inorganic materials nearby into
rubber and so on this would certainly be
a sick power up for him but if this is
all that's going on then the whole
joyboy's back stuff doesn't seem to be
related to it luffy's devil fruit could
awaken like katakuri's without luffy
dying and being reborn as joy boy so the
heavily emphasized joy boy connection
seems to indicate that there might be
more going on here because it's been
implied that the gomu gomonomi is not
the real name of luffy's devil fruit it
is possible that rubber related powers
are just one aspect of the fruit's full
potential maybe luffy can use other
abilities beyond just rubber based
powers and he just didn't realize it yet
for example maybe his actual ability is
closer to burning rubber so a
combination of fire and rubber or some
combination of rubber and lava or rubber
and some other element there is also a
lot of speculation that luffy's real
devil fruit may actually be a mythical
zone like the monkey king sudbu kong
fruit i think that this would be
extremely cool i've read a journey to
the west and soon bukong has some
awesome powers and of course luffy's
character definitely has that monkey
king energy but even though the monkey
king fruit would definitely be a good
fit for luffy the fact that this devil
fruit is a dangerous legendary fruit
that hasn't awakened for centuries means
that it is likely directly related to
joy boy and nika and i think that in
order to better understand how luffy's
new power could directly connect to two
legendary ancient figures like joy boy
nica we need to go back to the beginning
and by that i don't mean the voice entry
but even before the void century we need
to go back to over 1 100 years ago in
the world of one piece to the advanced
civilization that inhabited the moon the
same civilization whose descendants are
the modern day skypeans shandorians or
shandians and the beer [ __ ] but to find
the answers we need we first need to go
back 3500 years in our own world and
take a look at the olmec civilization of
mesoamerica now it is pretty clear that
the ancient civilization on the moon
along with all of their descendant
civilizations are heavily inspired by
ancient mesoamerican civilizations
including the aztecs and the mayans
the parallels are blatantly clear when
we look at the architecture art and
culture of these civilizations in one
piece and then compare them to the
real-life mesoamerican civilizations i
mean this particular statue of
quetzalcoatl the feathered serpent god
from aztec religion seems to have been
directly taken from real life and drawn
into one piece but while i've seen a lot
of talk about the sky civilizations
being inspired by the aztecs and mayans
i rarely hear talk about the olmecs who
predate the aztecs and mayans and
without whom the aztecs and mayans and
other mesoamerican civilizations would
not have existed the olmec are
considered to be the first major
civilization of ancient mexico and their
history dates all the way back to 1500
bc this is of course many centuries
before the aztec and mine empires would
flourish in mesoamerica it is believed
that the olmec civilization pioneered
many of the things that later
mesoamerican civilizations would become
known for including that famous mayan
calendar the ball games that the
mesoamerican people played and even the
gods that they worshipped it can all be
traced back to the olmecs so the olmecs
could be seen as the ancestors of the
mayans and aztecs just like the moon
civilization is the ancestor
civilization of the shandorians skypians
and beer cuts but here's the crazy thing
about the olmec people the name olmec
literally means the rubber people
because they lived in an area that was
known for producing rubber now olmec is
not what the people call themselves we
don't know what they call themselves but
this is the name given to them because
of the rubber producing area that they
inhabited the olmecs did not leave
behind any written history or oral
traditions so everything we know about
them comes from artifacts and from the
influence that their civilization had on
other civilizations that came later if
this gives you the same vibes as the
moon civilization and the void century
trust me you're not the only one the
olmecs are probably best known for
creating giant head statues some of
which are over 3 meters in height in
other words these stone heads are just
big enough for a certain giant straw hat
to fit them and speaking of giants the
jaguar is a very important sacred animal
in mesoamerica so it is possible that
the giant jaguar d saul will turn out to
be more important than we even realize
now many people have heard about the
aztec god quetzalcoatl who often takes
the shape of a feathered serpent some
have discussed the potential connection
between luffy and quetzalcoatl in the
past especially because quetzalcoatl was
the god of the sun and of the dawn as
well as the winds and the sky nika of
course is the sun god joy boy and luffy
are going to bring about a new dawn so
quetzalcoatl the feathered serpent may
be an even better fit for luffy's
hypothetical mythical zone devil fruit
than the monkey king sun wukong but most
people don't realize that this divine
feathered serpent that the aztecs
worshiped as quettal koatl actually
originated with the olmecs the olmecs
the rubber people also worshipped a
feathered serpent deity if the sky races
represent the newer civilizations such
as the aztecs and mayans then the moon
civilization represents the olmecs and
so the truth about nika joyboy and the
true nature of luffy's legendary devil
fruit may lead all the way back to the
moon itself now i'm not saying this will
happen because we already have two major
dragons in wano but it would be pretty
insane to see kaido's dragon having to
face luffy's feathered serpent form with
like burning rubber all over his body
anyway the similarities between nika
joyboy and the feathered serpent deity
that came to be known as quetzalcoatl
don't end there the rulers of ancient
mesoamerica would often equate
themselves with quetzalcoatl implying
that they were his current incarnation
or reincarnation on earth the aztec
people believed that quetzalcoatl would
one day return to earth and according to
some historical sources when hernan
cortes and the conquistadors landed in
america in 1519 aztec emperor montezuma
ii believed that cortes was actually
quetzalcoatl returning to claim his
throne whether this is true is actually
still disputed by historians but this
idea of quetzalcoatl being incarnated in
different rulers and returning to earth
to claim his throne definitely gives off
strong joy boy and nika energy side note
but gone fall and his armor seem to be a
direct reference to spanish
conquistadors which again stresses the
parallels between mesoamerica and the
sky people even in terms of his
personality what we know about
quetzalcoatl echoes what we know about
joy boy and nika although in modern
western culture serpents are often
associated with sinister things
quetzalcoatl was actually a kind and
gentle deity and he did not want to harm
any living creature he was a benefactor
of mankind and he gifted them incredibly
valuable knowledge including things like
farming medicine and other important
crafts he was loved by the people and he
brought them joy oh and if you're
looking for a monkey connection in his
form as ehekar he is the wind and he is
represented by spider monkeys among
other creatures so if the key to luffy's
new transformation and the ending of one
piece itself lies with the olmecs and
their mesoamerican descendants do we
have any clues about what luffy's new
powers could be well right off the bat
shape-shifting is a very popular power
among mesoamerican gods including
quetzalcoatl and since he can take the
form of a giant feathered serpent he can
also fly and his powers are associated
with the sun the sky and wind that of
course gives us many options to
speculate about in terms of the direct
rubber connection the ancient
mesoamericans were the first people to
invent rubber balls and they were a very
important part of their culture these
rubber balls could be used for playing
ball games or as important religious
offerings among other uses another aztec
god who represents the morning star
venus and whose name can be translated
as dawn lord or lord of the dawn is
associated with powerful rays that are
able to hurt people and crops the
interesting thing about this deity is
that there is a known image of him
burning a rubber ball so again that
whole burning rubber and melting rubber
aspect could come into play also you
might have noticed that i didn't tell
you this deity's name so i guess i have
to do that now
his name is tlauis kalpatikutli
now it is important to mention that to
both the aztecs and the maya the rubber
latex that flowed from the tree
represented blood and semen rubber was
symbolic of fertility of new life and it
was often burned buried or laid in
sacrificial pools as an offering to
deities now i don't think that luffy's
power will be related to that other
thing but something associated with
blood could be a part of the equation
bloodletting played a massively
important part in mesoamerican religions
and luffy has already used a form of
blood manipulation as far back as gear
2. he has also used air manipulation to
blow air into his own body so that wind
and air connection to quetzalcoatl could
also come into play all in all i think
that there are many fascinating theories
regarding luffy's new forms and powers
and his connection to joy boy i'm a fan
of many of them but i don't think we can
underestimate the importance of the
rubber people the olmecs and all the
other mesoamerican connections to the
ancient kingdom the void century and the
civilization on the moon joy boy nika
the gomu gomi and the one piece itself
are all going to take us back to the
ancient kingdom and the best clues that
we have about the true nature of that
kingdom are the real life kingdoms that
inspired it let me know what you guys
think about luffy's new transformation
what is his connection to joy boy and
nika is he inheriting this divine will
is he himself a reincarnation of this
legendary warrior or is something else
going on then of course what new powers
do you think luffy is about to unlock
are we talking awakened gomugamunomi a
completely new element like fire or lava
or does he actually possess a mythical
zone fruit like the sunbu kung fruit or
the feathered serpent fruit don't forget
to leave your feedback down in the
comments below if you guys enjoyed this
one piece video and you want to see more
in the future leave a quick like and
comment it only takes a second but it
helps a lot and remember that
subscribing and hitting that
notification bell is a very real and
completely free way of supporting the
channel you can also hit me up on
twitter and instagram at animeopror as
always thank you guys so much for
watching and until next time see ya
space cowboys